I've got denell on the phone from
Virginia how can I help you hi Chris I
should pick in my car they appreciate it
just boom so I have a huge mess I have
three hundred thousand dollars in debt
and about two hundred sixty-eight is
student loans and I have about twenty
six in a car payment I got a new car
when I moved to Virginia and about nine
thousand in a personal loan trying to
get rid of my credit cards and other
things so that I could start on this
path financial freedom of a net apiece
okay but my situation is that I'm a
single mom so I have a four month old
and the dad he's not paying any child
support or anything like that
so I'm taking care of him trying to get
my finances in order
trying to tackle said so far suspended
by my company matching they give six
percent I completely stopped doing that
and I wasn't sure where I should put
this money if I should use it to build
an emergency savings or I should pay off
my lowest loans first you know not
really sure okay yeah
Danelle let me ask you this how long
have you been been battling this debt
since I graduated from my bachelor's you
undergrad how long ago was that okay and
you did graduate with your degree okay
how old are you young lady I'm 35 35
and you said you're a single mom so
what's your household income I make a
hundred and seven okay all right and so
what caused you to want to do something
about this debt I just I just can't live
like this anymore I feel like I'm living
like that backwards like I'm drowning
like I'm not getting anywhere I'm not
gonna be able to provide for my son
teach him an actual responsibility that
I never learned when I was younger right
so yeah this is kind of you know having
being a mom definitely fulfill that
absolutely it does it changes things and
it causes us to kind of really look at
where we are
where we want to be and I'm proud of you
for making that decision and this is as
you said this is a lot of debt I mean
268,000 and student loan debt how many
degrees do you have I have maybe four or
but it's because I didn't understand the
student loan process where I kept on
deferring is doing forbearance and the
interest kept on accruing and so that's
basically why it's snowball to this
amount okay and then I got my masters
recently but that something that I got
myself and I had a scholarship and stuff
like that I don't care it's kind of [ __ ]
okay so with this as you're looking at
it are you familiar with the baby steps
okay and so in that process the reason
why we do it that way is we we know that
without a doubt progress can be made but
we have to follow us a plan it's almost
like when you're cooking you need a
recipe and so for financial freedom you
need a recipe you got to know some steps
to take and so baby step number one is
to get a thousand dollars saved up
Danelle okay and that's gonna be your
starter emergency fund but after you
have that that's fantastic you want to
put that in a money market account or a
savings account just put it somewhere
where it's not within reach and you were
earmarking that as emergency fund so if
something happens with the car or
whatever you you've got money to fix it
but baby step two is where you listen
out your debts smallest to biggest and
you're throwing every dime at this debt
okay and so looking at this your
smallest student loan is you got the
nine thousand dollar personal loan so
you would break down the student loans
and list them in order and then from
there what you're going to do is begin
to work and to focus and this is you
know you've got you making one hundred
and seven hundred and seven thousand
dollars a year so you've got a good
income but now it's time to make
progress and now you're gonna dig your
way out and it's gonna be a process and
it's not gonna be easy it's gonna
require you being very focused but I
hear it in your voice becoming a new mom
at that little boy when you look at that
baby you know you want better for your
child
well the only way as a parent our child
can have better is if we do better and
so you following this process it's not
going to be easy I'm just telling you
it's gonna be worthwhile I'm telling you
that you are going to feel a sense of
not only responsibility but like you're
taking your life back you mentioned you
say it feels like you're drowning
because this debt right I get that but
we have had people dig their way out
time after time and it's gonna require
being really really focused I'm gonna
send you and gift to Financial Peace
University Financial Peace University is
a nine week course that allows you to
really dig in and start to understand
this money stuff on a different level
like there's a difference between head
knowledge and heart knowledge head
knowledge means you understand some
things like we know that debt is not our
friend right we know this but inevitably
because of our culture were marketed to
and we end up falling for the POI why we
end up falling for that trick we're not
no more you're gonna have an opportunity
to learn and understand budgeting that
you're gonna tell your money where to go
you're gonna understand about attacking
debt about saving and about investing
but also being able to build wealth once
you get out of debt so you can give and
it's a game changer
Danelle I'm telling you you've got an
opportunity with your four month old son
to work this process and get to a point
to where he'll never know that it ever
existed because you're gonna put
yourself on a different playing field
you're gonna have opportunities ahead of
you so I want you to buckle down as a
single mom I want you to know I come
from a single-parent home and I
understand what happens when when when a
single parent gets serious and gets
focused and committed good things happen
and so you've got an opportunity to make
an impact not only on your son but if
your friends and other people around you
so I love that you're making a statement
for you and that you're committed and
digging into this and gonna stay focused
and I'm telling you going to a Financial
Peace University will give you the tools
that you need you have to supply the
energy and the effort and I know that
that's something that you can do